we've been talking a lot about I mean
obviously this year there's been a lot
of there's like it's been a diverse
range of protagonists and games which is
a great thing like regardless like a
gives us dim perspectives different kind
of it's not always just this nathan
drake Master Chief I mean the Master
Chief like being just like bomb he is
white just white dude and at the end of
halo 4 they show it quick but uh yeah we
just want to talk about between like
mafia three watchdogs to just like the
entire cast of overwatch for better or
worse like all pretty-like cool new
protagonist but we've brought you on
just because we want to talk about kind
of like you've been you played a lot of
games here we want to talk about like I
don't know what you think about certain
protagonist figured it'd be as good a
time as any to talk about it because I'm
trying to think ahead dead rising for
Frank West is coming back which people
are pretty excited about I don't
necessarily like him he's boring he has
a camera he's a journalist yeah yeah I
don't know The Last Guardian is a pretty
cool like side character Treecko the
animal but I don't know other than that
just like I feel like all the cool
protagonist are out this year so I don't
know Michael who are you're like some of
your favorites oh well looking looking
back at 2016 we've seen a shift or we've
seen a lot more diversity and characters
and at first in the euro overwatch stood
out to me because half the cast is
female and they're all day range in
terms of nationalities and that was
really it was really fun to see because
it came naturally as well like when you
follow their backstories it all made
sense and all played into this this
theme of overwatch like the world coming
together and stuff like that for
backstory so it made sense there and
also going to mafia 3 with Lincoln clay
and the themes that mafia 3 was trying
to portray as a black man in the 1960s
well oh and it did it in a very again
like a natural way it wasn't like forced
and same thing with watch dogs but a
little bit different in terms of you
know the themes there's not as much
emphasis on racism because mafia 3 is a
lot about race that is a central theme
to it and I think that hangar 13 did a
a genuine job because it's very touchy
to do that sort of thing and I think
that 2016 looking back is that we saw a
lot of inclusiveness and on the force
the way either I feel ya know it was
like I don't know I for mafia three
years all you know like cetera in 1968
like probably one of the worst years in
American history in terms of like you
know like racism just all around like
political problems between like you know
Vietnam was kind of like toward the end
of the conflict in everything but
Lincoln clay didn't make sense within
the world it didn't feel like ham fisted
he he himself was a you know suffering
from PTSD at a time when like PTSD was
still not understood at all they call
this a shell-shocked I believe still he
was coming back you know like you said a
black man in the and you know Louisiana
new Bourdeaux in this case it's just
like you know a kind of a portmanteau of
New Orleans and whatnot New Orleans
influences but it didn't make sense I
felt like he was really kind of you know
he was central to this story it's it's
unfortunate the rest of the game at
least in my opinion wasn't as fun as
like I really loved seeing a story I
loved watching where we go next I've
only played like six hours but like the
intro itself had me hooked right away
between the setting but I do feel like
Lincoln clay you know delivered that I
think like he was a nuanced character
you know he wasn't just the black man he
was you know with PTSD he was like this
person who had never really had home
he's searching for a family his whole
life he's conflicted between you know
like his revenge tale with like I don't
want to spoil anything earlier but like
obviously like having a revenge tale
like like fuel it was kind of like
Tarantino influences which we spoke to
the dow national thing a lot like the
Pawnee like the punisher in like new
orleans in 1968 which is really cool did
you finish mafia 3 i got about like 15
hours in am I'm when I play games like
specially open-world games I do a lot of
side stuff and that kind of detracts
from like the pacing a little bit a huge
game too yeah like 40 hours i think if
you want to like do a decent amount of
the things you can in that game yeah but
i mean the the story itself is and
watching lincoln developed through the
story is kind of the driving factor and
i really enjoyed mafia one in mafia two
so this is a definitely a step in a
different direction I've always enjoyed
the story as well yeah but yeah the
especially like the voice acting in
mafia is very genuine
a lot of like the the themes and the
vernacular is I mean a lot of this
reminds me of home almost like the
people I grew up with yeah so in that
way it's like subtly cathartic to play a
game like mafia 3 and also watch dogs
too yeah go into like the modern day and
yeah like the tech world and stuff like
that shriya watchdogs to obviously much
more grounded and like modern tropes and
everything but again like Marcus
Holloway Bob black man from Oakland he's
a he's a bit younger than Marcus or
sorry from Lincoln from what I
understand but of like he I think he
seems a little more you know I don't
love the hacker culture tropes that use
in watch dogs to I'm having a lot of fun
and watch dog suit from what I played
but again this is someone who grew up in
Oakland and had witness like police
brutality for much of his life and it
wasn't a norm I wouldn't say but it was
it was not as like shocking to someone
say in the San Francisco tech bubble and
I think that's watching the like his
someone with his background and some of
his friends background collide with that
kind of new tech hacker culture was
really interesting to me i don't know
like did you play much of watchdogs to
as well yeah I played about 5-6 hours
i'm still getting to grips with it but I
mean the tone is like very different
from from mafia 3 obviously it's a more
happy-go-lucky kind of stuff but it does
yeah you know touch on certain themes of
like what's it like to be a person of
color in the tech world how do people
see you and yeah but it doesn't like dig
into that very deeply at least from what
I've seen and what I expect of like what
other people have been saying about it
but it's still like a fun game and it's
nice to like to see like things that are
familiar to me and it's not like with
all these games that are like in in
there putting in different protagonists
it's not that they're trying to create
diversity for diversity sake right it
makes sense in the context of the world
right and I think that you know is as
silly as watchdogs to is I think it
still does a pretty good job of you know
making sense in the context of the game
story yeah saying the Mafia 3 and also
over watch as we mentioned and also
i also want to like talk about quattro
calvin roger Odelia obscure indie game
about the theme is like 1980 in 1980s a
hacker hacker culture yeah and it
features an all-female cast but it's
it's made by blender games so they have
like this this paper arts styled like
Blockheads it's right if you're familiar
with 30 flights of loving it looks kind
of like jazzpunk if i'm not mistaken or
very similar to that job simulator
almost that kind of like that that our
direction yeah as a that type of art
style I love that kind of stuff but the
way tells the story is very subtle
there's no voice acting it's all about
context clues and it's like 33 females
that are who are hackers and it's kind
of this tale of friendship and doing
really weird heists in like nineteen
eighty cyberpunk thing and I think that
all the subtle details in that game are
really what made it special and because
the story was it wasn't told to you you
have to find the story for yourself and
I thought that that was it was a nice
touch it was a nice change of pace as
well as like the open-world games where
you walk through the story where this
cents you like I mentioned you find it
for yourself so do you did you like the
characters in quadra hello cowboy aside
from the fact that like the way the
story was told yeah i think that uh i
mean you you kind of like see pictures
throughout the throughout the store you
see pictures of like their history with
each other and you've kind of you kind
of like tell yourself the story and i
really liked it in that sense and
there's also the different gameplay
elements for each like there's a point
where you can swap between all the
characters and their different abilities
towards the end of the game and i think
that that also played into how each
character fits like their role in this
this heist kind of theme and hacking
stuff like that ya khwaja cowboy i never
played much but I know like it did kind
of make it didn't come out of nowhere
but a lot of people are all of a sudden
saying you should play his game i still
haven't unfortunately but it's a little
strange it's a little bit of a barrier
to entry with in terms of like
understanding like what am I supposed to
do in this game but here i think it's
it's fairly short and it's
fairly cheap as well cool so I think
that like you know it's a nice change of
pace cool yeah they want touch back on
overwatch maybe like we were talking
about it earlier in the show I've been
playing a lot I actually wrote like an
editorial when Anna was released I think
Anna herself was a really good microcosm
of why i love that cast how often do you
see like this badass mother figure not
in like the reason i love that game
storytelling is again because you just
said with quadrilateral cowboy damn
that's a mouthful yeah I'm stumbling on
every type of man every like I love that
Ana's abilities kind of fact like and
the fact that she's a mother kind of
intertwined like her abilities very much
she's watching over her whole team
obviously if you if she's Pharaoh's
mother um like kind of like she'd think
Farrah thought she was dead for a while
if i'm not mistaken with the backstory
the lore um but you know she's healing
people she's putting people to sleep
it's not a very lethal thing she's just
saying like chill out but like seriously
relax just listen to take a nap right
yeah just need to take a nap says if she
does it to ferret during for us all i
think which is great but there's so many
of these little nuances hidden and the
fact that she's just kind of she's
coming back out of hiding because she
feels his protection and i really like
that like i don't know I my friend was
saying like he he's playing the game and
then she was like his mom had asked
something about it then like I mean how
often do you again it not often you see
is like badass mom character in a game
like I'm searching my brain right now I
can't figure out on a spot but she just
was like she was like a micro like the
best example for i love this cast I mean
you have a [ __ ] cowboy the revolver
you have a scientifically inclined a
prancing around you have I don't know
like this Jump Jet equipped rocket
launcher Egyptian security guard it's
just it's it's a colorful cast as it is
just like looking at like the art style
and everything and you can immediately
recognize a character from far away and
like know what they might do against you
in the gameplay but when you actually
get into even if you don't get in the
back story and lore it's still these
really cool there's a really diverse
cast and like you said like have more
female I think and now like the last two
Adelaide zambrano the last two eddins
were feel as well and it's like it's
just fun and like you can just play
different characters and like have their
different abilities and all just makes
sense yeah I'm still waiting for like
someone from I
erlend I'm not on my I'm like second
generation Irish but not like the late
great Danny O'Dwyer he's not dead this
late in terms of GameSpot stuff Daniel
Dwyers very much alive and very well
right now oh boy he might be watching I
have no idea I'm not Irish like yet
about any of that yeah no but yeah cool
so I mean it is it has been a great
landmark year for like new protagonist
which we've been you know kind of
pushing for last few times like again I
loved uncharted 4 it's one of my
favorite games of the year I gave it a
10 out of 10 making Drake I actually
thought they did a great job with like
telling his story but like characters
like that after a while kind of I think
we need something new and I think we
have people we need people that are like
are willing to tell those stories and
like tell them well yeah shame on and
it's it's not like you know there's not
a place for characters like Nathan Drake
of course like you know when you talk
about inclusiveness you want everybody
sure so I mean it's not like there's
anything wrong with having that sort of
protagonist so sure yeah and like also
to mention like Battlefield one with the
Bedouin woman share her sequence and
like the Harlem Hellfighters being
involved in the battlefield one story
and also you know playing Emily and
dishonor to sue I was like super hyped
up yes honor to because I was like oh
Emily's grown up like she's a playable
character like let's go right dope and
she's got like her own abilities I like
separated from courville and I don't
like ragging it too much this is a brief
tangent that I want to talk about
corvo's voice acting what were they
doing that's originally why he is so
good / yeah that's why I chose Emily cuz
I heard his voice is like no I can't
listen to this the entire game Emily and
fortunately Emily I thought was really
well done her very well great and her
character was pretty cool too although
characterizations not as strong I feel
like and dishonored is it is in mafia
three or even like overwatch I feel like
there was a lot more yeah I feel like
dishonored more about that like player
agency kind of choice rather than actual
narrative and what not wish to be honest
it's kind of weird that they gave them
voices this time around cuz I yeah Corvo
de Corvis sounded the first one and that
made a lot of sense to me because it was
just kind of like you play as you want
you know and you like project yourself
onto the character because he's not
spoken but uh they brought the corbels
voice actors the same as thief
from me and like beef is like one of my
favorite games of all time and it's like
I'm a little disappointed that that fell
flat because I also felt like a [ __ ]
bows no flesh or you know the original
like also looking like she's also one of
the nine voice actors in Skyrim to again
there's more than nine hundreds of
people yeah but like you if you place
karma you hear that way actually I think
was the first duty talk to isn't he in
the cart the storm guard there to the
storm cloak oh he telling that for some
reason I thought he was one of the
people from the the dark brotherhood he
might be he could be anybody yeah or he
give me the dragon I have no idea no
he's not the dragon I don't think but
who knows in that game do they add more
voice actors in remastered no I don't
think so of course not anyway cool so
that was I like we wanted to have a
discussion about the protagonist year
there have been like I said there have
been some great ones and they've been
well told and everything so uh I don't
let us know what you guys think if
you're watching this let us know in the
comments below what your favorite
protagonist were this year
[Music]